- You have to understand
you can do nothing right
for the next seven years
start putting it together
on your thirtieth birthday
and still have plenty of
time to achieve everything.
(upbeat music)
if you could be the
layer above the internet
you are the world, that's
what Amazon, Google,
Apple and Facebook fight for.
We fight for being the best
practitioner on that next level.
Got it?
That's the game, that's where nobody sees
the macro of all this,
that's why I'm good.
- But it's the thing I'm grappling with.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- So I can scrape the bottom of the barrel
and take the rest of the
ice cream in the carton
'cause there's still some in there.
- 100%.
- Or I can use my energy
and time to try to create
provisions for the future
and change mindset.
One's a morality play,
one's a land grab for money.
- Well I mean, to me, the
morality play always works
'cause you end up with more money.
Everybody's watching.
Let me say this brother.
Listening to your situation
and ending with this.
People watch it.
- Yeah.
- So just keep being
right, the number one thing
that has allowed all my
happiness and success
is never wavering from
my 100% pure opinion
and having it documented whether it's just
20 people in the room, everybody
watched, at a conference
just be historically correct,
that shit will work out
somebody is watching.
In a world that's changing so quickly
where everything is transparent,
where everything you do is captured,
with Flickr and YouTube and
Twitter and Quick and Kite
and things to that nature where
every part of your movement
is captured, what's going to happen
is that people that are
good, that are awesome,
that come from the heart are going to win
and people that are bad that
have horrible intentions
are going to lose, understand this.
Anything you do is going to be known.
You're not gonna be able to
have multiple personalities
one for the chicks, one
for business, one for this
uh-uh, it's over, you are
who you are now in this world
and you need to understand
that very quickly.
Your personal brand now is completely
exposed to the world 24/7.
Everybody, my friends, is now the media
and because of this, the
media's a great equalizer
and everything you do will
be exposed and unraveled.
So try to think very hard what
you want to be to the world.
The only thing I do for a living
is I reverse-engineer
who I'm trying to get to.
The only reason I did
that video with A Boogie
is 'cause I wanted you to see it.
All I do is pay attention to attention.
Right and then I reverse back
to what's happening in culture
and that's how I think about things.
That's how you think about
selling, it's all about empathy.
One of the great traits that
I wish all of you can develop
is also one of the best business traits
and what makes people get sales people.
If I actually care more about you
than I care about what I want
then I start thinking in that way.
When I walked in here right now
even the references I'm making
it's to make it interesting for you.
So when you try to sell
your safety product
you've gotta figure out who's
making that buying decision
and are you bringing them value
not what's fun for you.
If you want to do what's fun for you
then sell something that's fun for you.
What I'm doing right now
is I'm going to offices
because last night I sent
an email around 11 p.m.
that I wanted the organization to remember
even though 98% is doing it
I want 100% kindness and empathy
throughout the organization
so I'm just kind of making some
inside jokes with the company.
Is everybody being kind in here?
Is this a kind conversation?
- Very kind.
- All right good.
- Yes very kind.
- [Woman On Phone] Per se, so.
- [Woman] Oh my God, you
scared me, it's just--
- [Gary] Shit I was trying to mute it.
- [Woman] Are you kidding?
(laughing)
- [Gary] Somebody call in, I'm so sorry.
- [Woman] Blend it
anyway, for the production
and then I'll drop that in here
and if it needs to go into 27 then
I'll just make a note of
that, oh hi (chuckles)
- [Gary] Hey.
Just checking in, making sure everybody
is being kind in this meeting.
- [Woman] We're always kind, yes.
- [Male] No, not at all.
- [Woman] This is the kindness we will--
- [Gary] Is everybody
being kind in this meeting?
- Oh my God, you scared me.
(laughing)
- [Gary] Is everybody being
super kind in this meeting?
- [All] Yes!
- Okay, awesome.
9-8-0.
- 9-8-0
6-7-8
7-1-4
8-0-1.
- Eli, this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Eli] What?
- Yeah!
- [Eli] No way.
- Yeah, it really is Eli.
- [Eli] What, it's so awesome
to hear from you Gary.
How are you doing?
- I'm tremendous, I wanted
to take a quick second
and thank you for buying the
t'shirt from First In Line.
- [Eli] Wow, yeah, oh I was
excited to see it go up.
So thank you for the opportunity.
I actually was able to get me a pair
of the Crushing It shoes
off the First In Line drop
that you did the other day online too
so I was pretty stoked on that.
- You were one of those
people that actually got it?
- [Eli] Yeah I was one of the 25 (mumbles)
- That's fucking what's up, man.
- And I just wanna let you
know too, I'm sitting on them.
I'm gonna sit on them for a while.
- 10 G's baby, 10 G's.
Everybody's gonna laugh and then one day
you're gonna fucking
kill it with that, Eli.
- [Eli] That's what I was thinking too.
I've just been paying
attention to what you're saying
and everybody is looking for the short 400
but I'm gonna hold onto
them and get when it counts.
- I love it man, well listen
I hope you have the best day ever.
- [Eli] Thanks Gary, I
hope you have the same
and I really appreciate that call
it was awesome to hear from you.
- Thanks brother, take care.
What can I answer for you?
- So something--
- Can you find me Marcus?
- Something that I was just
thinking about recently
so since I graduated, I
was in school for like
16 years of my life.
- Yeah.
- And I find the transition
a little bit difficult in--
- Because that was so structured?
- Yes.
- Yeah I mean honestly,
don't beat yourself up.
- Yeah.
- You landed in the right place.
We're not gonna beat you up.
- You don't (chuckles)
everyone's so inviting.
- So I think you're beating yourself up.
You're five seconds out.
- I know.
- The end.
- That's definitely the hardest part
'cause I always used to say, like
yeah you always have, like,
oh project for three months
you're done, like you did great A
and now it's like, okay now
it's like you always say
it's like a long game, it's like all right
when do you finally see the
fruits of your labor come out
and you never know when it'll happen,
when it'll actually complete.
- Yeah and it's like,
the fruits of your labor
a fruits of your labor conversation at 23
to me is ludicrous, you know?
I get it, but I want to get you out of it.
- I know and--
- I was 34 years old when I
left my dad's liquor store
and like, had nothing.
I build my dad's liquor store for him
didn't make that much money,
and was just starting at 34.
You know what advice I would,
listen I don't know enough yet
but like, intuitively right
now in this limited time
I feel like literally making a rule
that you can think about
anything other than
one day at a time having
fun, learning, being young
for the next 24 months, like not allowed.
You have to wait until your 25th birthday
to even start debating
what's happening here
would be monumentally impactful on you.
- That feels, I feel
like a lot of pressure
taken off my shoulder
just thinking like that.
- You have to understand,
you can do nothing right
for the next seven years,
start putting it together
on your thirtieth birthday
and still have plenty of
time to achieve everything.
25, no judging, no
debating, no even pondering
if this is good, bad, getting you
to where you need to or not.
- Okay.
- I'm being serious with you, I think
that gets you where you
want to get to way faster
than debating it in the short term.
You need to take a little
steam out of the engine
and take a breath a little bit.
- Okay.
- It will help you.
It'll get a lot more quiet
which will create a lot more room.
(soft music)